This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. For centuries, physicians regarded fever as a dangerous disease, an enemy to be crushed. In ancient and medieval medicine, fever was thought to represent an excess of heat or humor in the blood, a sign that the body's internal balance had gone dangerously askew. Treatments aimed to drive out the heat. Patients were bled, purged, or doused with cold water. Some were packed in ice. or fed diets designed to cool the blood.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。几个世纪以来，医师一直将发烧视为一种危险的疾病，是必须被消灭的敌人。在古代和中世纪的医学中，人们认为发烧代表血液中热量或体液过剩，是身体内部平衡严重失调的迹象。治疗的目的是驱散热气。患者会被放血、催吐或用冷水泼洒。有些人被包裹在冰块中，或者食用旨在冷却血液的饮食。
Well into the 19th century, fever was still widely feared as a destructive force that could consume a person from within. Doctors prescribed mercury-based compounds, quinine, or alcohol in large quantities. Patients were subjected to fever cures in which they were submerged in prolonged cold baths or were wrapped in vinegar-soaked sheets,
直到19世纪，发烧仍然被广泛恐惧，被视为一种能够从内部吞噬一个人的破坏性力量。医生们开出大量基于汞的化合物、奎宁或酒精。患者要接受退烧治疗，即将他们长时间浸泡在冷水中，或者用浸过醋的床单包裹，
all in the hope of forcing the body's temperature back down. It wasn't until the late 90s, and early 20th centuries that scientists began to recognize fever not as a disease, but as a natural response of the body's immune system. Research showed that infections, not fever, were the real enemy. Studies showed that moderate fever actually helped the body fight infection by slowing the growth of bacteria and enhancing immune function. This shift marked a profound change in medical thinking.
这一切都是为了强行将体温降下来。直到90年代末和20世纪初，科学家们才开始认识到发烧不是一种疾病，而是身体免疫系统的一种自然反应。研究表明，感染而不是发烧才是真正的敌人。研究表明，中度发烧实际上通过减缓细菌生长和增强免疫功能来帮助身体对抗感染。这一转变标志着医学思想的深刻变革。
of reflexively suppressing fever, physicians began to see it as evidence of the body's vitality and capacity for self-defense. Today, while very high fevers are still considered dangerous and treated, mild to moderate fevers are often allowed to run their course. A quiet acknowledgement that what was once seen as a deadly illness is, in fact, a sign of the body's strength. Today on the show, we investigate the possibility that what is true of our physical health may also be true of our mental health, that even a scourge like depression may have its roots in our powerful drive
不再本能地抑制发烧，医师们开始将其视为身体活力和自卫能力的证明。今天，虽然非常高的发烧仍然被认为很危险并需要治疗，但轻度到中度发烧通常被允许自然病程结束。这是一种默许：曾经被视为致命疾病的东西，实际上是身体强壮的标志。今天在节目中，我们探讨这样一种可能性：适用于我们身体健康的规律同样也适用于我们的心理健康，即像抑郁症这样的灾难可能根植于我们强大的生存和繁荣驱动力中。
to survive and flourish. The origins of depression this week on Hidden Brain. A note that this story includes a discussion of suicide. If you are someone you love is struggling with thoughts of suicide, there are people who can help. Call or text the suicide and crisis lifeline at 988. If you're outside the U.S., we've included a link in our episode notes where you can find
抑郁症的根源，本周《隐藏的大脑》。请注意，这个故事包含对自杀的讨论。如果您或您爱的人正在与自杀念头作斗争，有人可以提供帮助。请拨打或发短信至“自杀与危机生命热线”988。如果您在美国境外，我们在分集简介中附了一个链接，您可以在那里找到您所在国家的心理健康支持。
mental health support in your country. We live in a culture that prizes strength and confidence and that celebrates happiness and high mood. So when those things slip away, when our energy disappears, when joy goes missing, we naturally assume that something must have gone very wrong. We look for a problem to fix, a disease to cure. At Cornell University, psychologist Jonathan Rottenberg has long asked if this is the right way to think about depression. John Rottenberg, welcome to Hidden Brain.
我们生活在一个崇尚力量和自信、赞美快乐和高昂情绪的文化中。因此，当这些东西溜走时，当我们的精力消失时，当快乐不见踪影时，我们自然会认为一定出了很大的问题。我们寻找需要解决的问题，需要治愈的疾病。在康奈尔大学，心理学家乔纳森·罗滕伯格长期以来一直在询问这是否是思考抑郁症的正确方式。约翰·罗滕伯格，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you. It's wonderful to be here with you. 30 years ago, John, you were a confident, self-assured college graduate preparing to get married and to start a career. What was your life like at the time and what were your plans for the future? I was studying. I was in a PhD. program in history living in Baltimore. At Johns Hopkins University, I studied American history. And I thought I was the smartest guy in the room. And I was then struck by a series of very bizarre experiences that I had no framework for
谢谢。很高兴能和您在一起。30年前，约翰，你是一个自信、坚定的大学毕业生，准备结婚并开始职业生涯。你当时的生活是怎样的，你对未来的计划是什么？我在学习。我在巴尔的摩攻读历史学博士学位。在约翰斯·霍普金斯大学，我研究美国历史。我以为我是房间里最聪明的人。然后我遭遇了一系列非常奇异的经历，我没有任何框架来理解它们。
understanding. Tell me what happened. In many ways, you had all of your life before you. You had graduated from an Ivy League school. You were about to get married. You were doing this PhD and you thought you were the smartest person in the room. It felt like everything was going your way. Yes.
告诉我发生了什么。在很多方面，你的人生才刚刚开始。你毕业于常春藤盟校。你即将结婚。你在读这个博士学位，你以为你是房间里最聪明的人。感觉一切都在顺着你的心意发展。是的。
And so when I started to feel unwell, I didn't have really much of a framework to go on. I first noticed physical symptoms that did it. didn't make a whole lot of sense. I had pain on the left side of my body. I thought there might be something wrong with my heart. I felt physically weak. I thought I might have a fever or some kind of flu-like illness. I felt incredibly run down. And I thought that it would just go away on its own. and then other problems started. So rather than it getting better, it got worse. So what started to change was that my ability to focus, read, think that degenerated pretty rapidly.
所以当我开始感觉不舒服时，我其实没有什么框架可以依据。我首先注意到的是身体症状，这完全说不通。我身体左侧疼痛。我以为我的心脏可能出了问题。我感到身体虚弱。我以为我可能发烧了或者得了某种类似流感的疾病。我感到不可思议的精疲力竭。我以为它会自己消失，然后其他问题就开始出现了。所以它不仅没有好转，反而恶化了。所以开始改变的是，我专注、阅读、思考的能力迅速退化。
So this tool that I used to understand the world, this tool that really defined who I was, my brain, my mind, was not working right. So here I am in a history program and I'm working on a dissertation and I can't read a book. I mean, I can look at a page and I see the words and my ability to concentrate is getting to be close to zero. So I started to get scared. What could explain this? So I was even more baffled and I felt like something terrible was happening to me, but I didn't know what it was. At what point did this clarify itself? At what point did doctors come up with a diagnosis, John? It took months. I remember going home. I was living in Baltimore, driving home, and that was very difficult to Connecticut and meeting with.
所以我用来理解世界的这个工具，这个真正定义了我是谁的工具——我的大脑，我的思维，运作不正常了。所以我现在在一个历史项目里，我正在写毕业论文，而我读不了一本书。我的意思是，我可以看着一页纸，我能看到字，但我的专注力接近于零。所以我开始害怕了。什么能解释这一点？所以我更加困惑，我觉得有什么可怕的事情正在发生在我身上，但我不知道那是什么。什么时候情况变得清晰了？医生们是什么时候提出诊断的，约翰？这花了几个月时间。我记得我回家了。我住在巴尔的摩，开车回家，那真的很艰难，回康涅狄格州，并与一位我父亲同事的精神病学家见面，我相信那位同事是第一个提出这可能是抑郁症的人，这震撼了我的世界。
a psychiatrist who is a colleague of my father's, and I believe that colleague was the first person to suggest that this might be depression, and that rocked my world. The sensations I was experiencing were not what I understood to be the symptoms of depression, which were feeling sad or just losing interest in things. I was really more experiencing this terrible fatigue, this inability to concentrate. And so I did get a referral to see a psychiatrist in Baltimore, and I was started on medication. And unfortunately, it didn't help me. And I continued to struggle and become more and more distraught over the and less and less functional.
我当时的感受并不是我所理解的抑郁症症状，也就是感到悲伤或只是对事物失去兴趣。我其实更多地体验到这种可怕的疲劳，这种无法专注的感觉。所以我确实得到了去巴尔的摩看精神病医生的转诊信，我开始服药。但不幸的是，它并没有帮助我。我继续挣扎，对这种情况感到越来越烦躁，功能也越来越差。
So I was spending large parts of the day lying on the ground. Well, for someone who was so proud of his own mind and how his mind worked, I'm wondering if there was an element of shame that you felt as you were experiencing this. Yes, I felt humiliated and I felt completely like I didn't know who I was. if I couldn't think that I had no, I had no reason, I had no reason for being. I had no purpose in life. And it was, it was very, it was very scary in the fact that the treatment did not initially help me, made it worse. And, you know, I had support of my then girlfriend. and she stayed with me, but I became more and more difficult to be around.
所以我把大部分时间都花在躺在地上了。嗯，对于一个如此为自己的头脑和头脑运作方式感到自豪的人来说，我想在你经历这一切时，是否有一种羞耻感？是的，我觉得受到了羞辱，我完全觉得自己不知道我是谁。如果我不能思考，我就没有理由，我就没有生存的理由。我人生没有目标。而且，这非常可怕，事实上治疗最初并没有帮助我，这让情况更糟。而且，你知道，我当时的女友支持我，她留在我身边，但我变得越来越难相处。
I became more emotionally volatile. I spent hours and hours crying. I started to experience suicidal fantasies of not wanting to be alive or even believing that I simply wouldn't have a future. it became more and more difficult for me to imagine that I would have a future. I didn't see myself as ever being able to emerge from this because the depression felt like it was bigger than me. It was stronger than me. It was more powerful than me. And that was a horrible feeling of powerlessness.
我变得情绪不稳定。我花了几个小时又几个小时哭泣。我开始体验到不想活下去的自杀幻想，甚至相信我根本不会有未来。我越来越难以想象自己会有未来。我看不到自己能够从中走出来的希望，因为抑郁症感觉比我更大。它比我更强大。它比我更有力量。这是一种可怕的无力感。
I'm wondering how you viewed your future at this time, John. Did the path that seemed so bright some months earlier, did it seem that it had closed off for you? Completely. By this point, I had gone on leave from my history program. I had told my advisor that I was probably not coming back to the program, which was very, very difficult. And the path forward was very unclear.
我想知道你当时是如何看待你的未来，约翰。几个月前看起来那么光明的道路，对你来说似乎已经关闭了吗？完全关闭了。到这个时候，我已经从我的历史项目中请假了。我告诉我的导师我可能不会再回到这个项目了，这非常非常困难。前方的道路非常不明确。
I knew that I was, somehow continuing with my relationship with Laura, which was incredible that she was staying with me, but I wasn't sure that I was going to make it to the other side. I really had a lot of doubt that I was going to make it to the other side. And I was at my limit. Every day I felt I was at my absolute limit of what I could possibly bear. I thought that no person, no person can bear this. I mean, I felt completely obliterated. How long did your depression last, John, and how did it finally come to an end? It lasted, I guess you could say, four years, and it involved my really dedicating myself and sinking myself into the study of psychology, into the study
我知道我某种程度上在继续与劳拉的关系，她能留在我身边真是不可思议，但我并不确定我能撑过去。我真的对能否撑过去抱有很多怀疑。我达到了极限。每天我都觉得我达到了我所能承受的绝对极限。我想没有人，没有人能承受这个。我的意思是，我觉得自己彻底崩溃了。约翰，你的抑郁症持续了多久，它是如何最终结束的？它持续了，我想可以说，四年，这涉及我真正全身心投入并沉浸在心理学研究中，对情绪障碍的研究中。
of mood disorders. I applied to graduate school. I thought maybe I can rehabilitate myself. Maybe I can rehabilitate my mind. And miraculously, I was admitted to a PhD program, actually a really a tremendous PhD program at Stanford University, and that was where my wife's family was from, and so she was overjoyed. By that point, we were married and expecting a child. So there were things, I could imagine that there were things to live for, even if I felt like I was faking it every day. I was still struggling to concentrate. I did not feel confident in my ability to do this PhD, program, but I was going to try. And the idea that I would have the opportunity to understand depression, it felt like in my heart, my only chance. I think it was enough to gradually
我申请了研究生院。我想也许我可以重塑自己。也许我可以重塑我的大脑。奇迹般地，我被一个博士项目录取了，实际上是斯坦福大学一个非常棒的博士项目，那是我妻子家人所在的地方，所以她欣喜若狂。到那个时候，我们已经结婚并期待着一个孩子的出生。所以有一些事情，我可以想象有活下去的理由，即使我觉得自己每天都在假装。我仍然在努力集中注意力。我对完成这个博士项目没有信心，但我打算试一试。有机会了解抑郁症的想法，在我的内心深处，感觉是我唯一的希望。我想这足以逐渐推动我朝着我需要的方向前进。我算是回到了人间，但这一个渐进的过程。
move me in the direction that I needed to be. And I sort of returned to the land of the living, but it was a gradual process. When John Rottenberg first fell into a severe depression, he saw it through a particular lens. Like many of us, he had absorbed the notion that depression was a flaw in character or in brain chemistry. It took years for him to see his experience in a different light.
当约翰·罗滕伯格第一次陷入严重抑郁时，他是通过一个特定的镜头来看待它的。和我们许多人一样，他接受了这样一种观念：抑郁是性格或大脑化学成分上的缺陷。他花了多年时间才以不同的眼光看待自己的经历。
That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. For several decades now, we've been told that depression is a malfunction, a glitch in our brain chemistry, a flaw in our cognitive wiring.
我们一会儿回来。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。几十年来，人们一直告诉我们，抑郁症是一种机能失常，是我们大脑化学成分中的一个小故障，是我们认知线路中的一个缺陷。
But at Cornell University, psychologist John Rottenberg says this account may be wrong, or at least incomplete. John, how would you describe the prevailing model that we have of depression? The prevailing model that we have of depression is that depression reflects some fundamental defect that is inside the depressed person.
但在康奈尔大学，心理学家约翰·罗滕伯格表示，这种说法可能是错误的，或者至少是不完整的。约翰，你将我们对抑郁症的主流模式描述为什么？我们对抑郁症的主流模式是，抑郁症反映了抑郁者内心存在的某种根本缺陷。
that defect might be in the person's mind, like the way that the person thinks, or that defect might be in the person's brain, like in the chemicals that are circulating between the neurons, or that defect might be in how the person is interacting with other people. But in the final analysis, the reason that people are depressed is that they have some, fundamental defect or defects inside themselves that explain why they are subject to episode or repeated episodes of depression. You say that the defect model often blames depression on faulty brain chemistry and claims that antidepressants are the solution, but that the evidence doesn't fully support this idea. How so, John? People have been studying the biological contributions to depression for 50, 60, 70 years. And I do believe that part of depression involves biological factors, but that's very different from saying that there is a biological cause, a single cause, in the brain.
这种缺陷可能在人的思想中，比如人的思考方式，或者这种缺陷可能在人的大脑中，比如在神经元之间循环的化学物质中，或者这种缺陷可能在人与其他人互动的方式中。但归根结底，人们抑郁的原因是他们内心存在某种根本缺陷，这解释了为什么他们会遭受抑郁发作或反复发作。你说缺陷模式通常将抑郁症归咎于错误的大脑化学成分，并声称抗抑郁药是解决方案，但证据并不完全支持这种观点。为什么这么说，约翰？人们研究抑郁症的生物学贡献已经50、60、70年了。我确实相信抑郁症的一部分涉及生物学因素，但这与说大脑中存在生物学原因、单一原因有很大不同。
And the search for antidepressants has led to a large number. number of therapies, there's over 20, different antidepressants, but none of them could be called a cure. And I do think it's a bit misleading this metaphor that's often used to talk about a chemical imbalance because that imbalance has never been isolated. It's never been fully characterized. It can't be measured. And so what you have are treatments, which are useful for many people, but it relies on a metaphor. A patient comes in and wants help. The physician or a psychiatrist might tell them that they have a chemical imbalance, but the problem is you can't present to them their number,
寻找抗抑郁药的工作已经催生了大量的疗法，有20多种不同的抗抑郁药，但没有一种可以被称为治愈方法。而且我认为这种经常用来谈论化学失衡的比喻有点误导性，因为这种失衡从未被分离过。它从未被充分表征。它无法被测量。所以你拥有的是治疗方法，对许多人很有用，但它依赖于一个比喻。一个病人进来寻求帮助。医生或精神病学家可能会告诉他们有化学失衡，但问题是你无法向他们展示他们的数字，
and you can't show that the treatment is changing that number. So you're really engaging in hand-waving, and I don't think that's doing a full-refer. service to our level of knowledge and being fully candid with people who are really struggling. So this would be in contrast to something like, you know, if a physician worries that you have high cholesterol, you can take a blood test and actually show what your cholesterol levels are. And with the right medications, you can then show that your cholesterol levels are changing. You're saying that no similar system exists when it comes to something like depression. Correct. So one of the main...
你无法证明治疗正在改变那个数字。所以你实际上是在虚张声势，我认为这并没有完全对得起我们的知识水平，也没有对真正挣扎的人完全坦诚。这与以下情况形成对比：例如，如果医生担心你的胆固醇高，你可以做血液检查，实际显示你的胆固醇水平是多少。通过正确的药物治疗，你可以证明你的胆固醇水平正在改变。你是说在抑郁症之类的事情上，并不存在类似系统。正确的。所以主要的……
neurotransmitters that's implicated in this disease model or defect model is serotonin. There's no way to assay serotonin and give your reading where you are with respect to serotonin right now in your brain like you can with cholesterol or you can with insulin. So depression involves biology, but it's not a disease in the same way that diabetes is a disease or Huntington's disease is a disease. I mean, in that case, we know what genes are responsible and we understand what those genes are doing and how it relates to the symptoms of this neurological disorder. Depression, the understanding is much more diffuse. Like, maybe it has something to do with serotonin. Maybe it has something to do with dopamine. That's a very different
这种疾病模型或缺陷模型中涉及的神经递质之一是血清素。没有办法化验血清素并给出你在大脑中关于血清素所处位置的读数，就像你可以用胆固醇或胰岛素做到的那样。所以抑郁症涉及生物学，但它不是像糖尿病那样的疾病，也不是像亨廷顿舞蹈症那样的疾病。我的意思是，在这种情况下，我们知道哪些基因负责，我们了解这些基因在做什么以及它与这种神经系统紊乱的症状有何关系。对于抑郁症，这种理解要模糊得多。比如，也许它与血清素有关。也许它与多巴胺有关。这是一个截然不同的理解水平。
level of understanding. Another way to think about the defect model, blames depression on faulty cognition and claims that the solution is the right kind of psychotherapy. But you say that the evidence doesn't fully support this explanation either? Well, I think that all of these are valid therapies. So if you're struggling with depression, medications are an option and cognitive behavioral therapy is an option. And that's a good thing to have multiple options. But again, that's very different from saying, that the reason that people become depressed in the first place is because there is something fundamentally deficient in their cognition in the way that they're thinking. It could be instead
思考缺陷模式的另一种方式是，将抑郁症归咎于错误的认知，并声称解决方案是正确的心理治疗。但你说证据也并不完全支持这种解释？嗯，我认为所有这些都是有效的疗法。因此，如果你正在与抑郁症挣扎，药物是一种选择，认知行为疗法也是一种选择。拥有多种选择是一件好事。但同样，这与说人们一开始变得抑郁的原因是因为他们的认知、他们的思考方式存在根本缺陷，是有很大不同的。相反，可能是
that these changes in cognition are part of what's maintaining the depression, which is why the therapy can be useful. So I do believe that cognitive behavioral therapies can be really helpful not only in helping people resolve a depression episode, but the skills that are less. learned in cognitive behavioral therapy can be useful in keeping people well. So I do believe that cognition is a contributing factor to depression. But that, again, is different than saying that people who were depressed all are somehow defective or deficient in how they think about the world. John's point is not that medications and psychotherapy are ineffective and should be discarded.
认知上的这些变化正是维持抑郁症的部分原因，这就是为什么治疗会有用的原因。所以我确实相信认知行为疗法不仅在帮助人们解决抑郁发作方面非常有用，而且在认知行为疗法中学习到的技能对于保持人们健康也很有用。所以我确实相信认知是抑郁症的一个促成因素。但这与说抑郁的人在如何思考世界方面都有某种缺陷或不足，又是两码事。约翰的观点并不是说药物和心理治疗无效，应该被抛弃。
He thinks they have helped millions and could help millions more. His point is only that depression is not necessarily evidence that there is something wrong with the brain. In fact, he believes the capacity for depression is wired into the brain. There's no question that nature built us with the capacity for low mood. And once you have that capacity for low mood, you have the capacity for more serious, more severe, more long-lasting low mood. And so that is a very important adaptation. Mood is what is integrating all of the inputs, both inside of your body and outside in your environment. And mood is the thing that's asking the question, what should I do next?
他认为它们已经帮助了数百万人，并且可以帮助更多的人。他的观点只是，抑郁症并不一定证明大脑有什么不对劲。事实上，他认为抑郁的能力是写入大脑的。毫无疑问，大自然赋予了我们低落情绪的能力。一旦你有了这种低落情绪的能力，你就有能力产生更严重、更严重、更持久的低落情绪。所以这是一个非常重要的适应。情绪是将你体内和体外环境的所有输入整合在一起的东西；情绪是提出这样一个问题的东西：我接下来该做什么？
Is this environment that I'm in good for action or is it bad for action? And so low moods are unpleasant, just as pain is unpleasant, anxiety is unpleasant, but I think it's easier for people to see that pain is an evolved mechanism that allows us to protect our body from physical damage, and anxiety is a mechanism that allows us to avoid threats, but what is the purpose of mood? It's harder for people to see that mood itself could have a purpose, but it actually is sharing a great amount of similarity with anxiety, with pain and with other mechanisms like fever that are protecting us. From an evolutionary perspective, John, what do you think mood is actually doing for us?
我所处的这个环境适合行动还是不适合行动？因此，低落的情绪是不愉快的，就像痛苦是不愉快的，焦虑是不愉快的，但我认为人们更容易看到痛苦是一种进化的机制，它使我们能够保护我们的身体免受物理损害，焦虑是一种使我们能够避开威胁的机制，但情绪的目的是什么？人们很难看到情绪本身可以有目的，但它实际上与焦虑、痛苦以及保护我们的发烧等其他机制有着极大的相似性。从进化的角度来看，约翰，你认为情绪实际上在为我们做什么？
It's telling us should we proceed or should we stop. So if you think at the most basic level of a little foraging animal where it's reached a patch of grass where there are no leaves of grass to eat, And everywhere it looks, there's no leaves of grass to eat. Should the organism keep moving or should the organism stop? Rit large, imagine there's a famine and there's no food available. Mood is a stop mechanism. And when we come to humans, the situations that can prompt low mood become much more complicated than threats to your physical well-being.
它在告诉我们应该继续还是应该停止。因此，如果你从一个小的觅食动物的最基本层面来考虑，它到达了一片没有草叶可吃的草地，环顾四周，没有草叶可吃。这个生物应该继续移动还是应该停下来？放大来看，假设发生了饥荒，没有食物可吃。情绪是一个停止机制。当我们来到人类身上时，能够引发低落情绪的情况变得比对你身体健康的威胁复杂得多。
They involve also your future prospects for survival and reproduction. You experience low mood when there is a dilemma, and it is uncertain whether or not you should proceed or whether you should stop. And low mood forces you to think about the situation maybe longer than you would like. But without it, we would subject ourselves to harm and we would be moving forward rashly. I mean, think about what happens after someone dies. There's a funeral. Everyone comes together. They do not feel good, but they mark this as an important moment where I have to figure out who am I
它们还涉及你生存和繁衍的未来前景。当存在两难境地、并且不确定是否应该继续还是应该停止时，你就会体验到低落的情绪。低落的情绪迫使你思考这种情况的时间可能会比你想要的更长。但如果没有它，我们将使自己遭受伤害，并且会轻率地前进。我的意思是，想想某人死后会发生什么。有一个葬礼。每个人聚集在一起。他们感觉不好，但他们将这标志着一个重要的时刻：我必须弄清楚我是谁，以及没有这个人我将如何继续我的生活。我想每个人都会看到悲伤是一个自然的过程，一个不可避免的过程。这是一个跨文化的过程。它甚至在其他物种中也能观察到。像抑郁症一样，它再次非常令人不快。这是一个非常困难的状态。所以大自然并没有为我们的快乐进行优化。大自然真正关心的是我们能够生存和繁衍，而不是我们体验快乐。你知道，我的抑郁症实际上符合其中一些参数，因为我投入了如此多的精力在这个成为历史学家的生活计划中。我觉得我预感到我作为历史学家找工作会有困难。
and how will I continue without this person in my life. And I think everyone would see that grief is a natural process, an inevitable process. It's a cross-cultural process. It's even observed in other species. And it again, like depression, is very unpleasant. It's a very difficult state. So nature is not optimized for our happiness. Nature really cares more that we survive and reproduce than that we experience joy. You know, my depression actually fits some of these parameters in that I had invested so much in this life plan to become historian. and that I think I sensed that I was going to have difficulty getting a job as a historian.
而我的身体某种程度上在说，你不会追求这个了。所以我被迫违背意愿停下来重新考虑，并提出了一个新的生活计划，这绝对不是一个容易的过程。但最终确实让我走上了一条通往更可行未来的道路。你知道，前段时间我们在《隐藏的大脑》中与东北大学的莉萨·费尔德曼·巴雷特交谈过，当谈到情感世界时，她一个有趣且挑衅性的观点是，她认为情感是对世界的预测，而不是对世界的反应。它们基本上是指南，告诉我们：前进，寻找这个，这会很有趣，要兴奋，要有高能量；或者另一方面，退缩，小心，害怕，害怕，这里有危险。所以，当我们把情绪视为预测器而不是反应时，
And my body was kind of saying, you're not going to pursue this. And so I was forced to stop and reconsider kind of against my will and come up with a new life plan, which was not an easy process at all. But did ultimately put me on a path towards a more viable future for myself. You know, we talked with Lisa Feldman Barrett at Northeastern University some time ago on Hidden Brain, and one of her interesting and provocative ideas when it comes to the world of emotions is she argues that emotions are predictions about the world rather than reactions to the world. They are basically guides that tell us, go forward, seek this out, this is going to be fun, be excited, have high energy, or on the other hand, withdraw, be careful, be afraid, be afraid, something is dangerous here. So when we think about emotions as predictors as opposed to reactions,
这非常符合你的论点，即情绪在某种程度上是指示我们接下来该做什么的指南。我完全同意这一点。已经发生的事情就像泼出去的水。从进化的角度来看，这并不重要。举个例子，我记得9-11事件中看着飞机撞击双子塔，我感到直接的恐惧，我感到直接的悲伤，我感到直接的愤怒。但这与未来有关。真的，这些感觉与未来有关，因为存在关于谁做了这件事、接下来会发生什么以及我们在哪里是否安全的问题。不管是谁做了这件事都必须付出代价。我认为人们以为他们是在对已经发生的事情做出反应，但实际上是未来的影响使得
that fits very well with your thesis that moods in some ways are a guide telling us what to do next. I completely agree with that. What's already happened is spilled milk. From the perspective of evolution, it doesn't matter. To give an example, I remember 9-11 in watching the planes hit the towers, and I felt immediate terror and I felt immediate sadness and I felt immediate rage. But it was about the future. It really was, those feelings were about the future because there were the questions about who had done this and what would happen next and were we safe, where we were right now. And whoever did this had to pay. I think that people thought that they were reacting against what had happened, but it was really the implications for the future that made
这些感觉如此强烈。所以我同意我们的感觉是为了帮助我们在当下做我们需要做的事，这是一个面向未来的系统。为了更深入地探讨这一点，你告诉我你的抑郁症是如何令人衰弱的，你如何觉得看不到尽头，你甚至有结束自己生命的念头。一个如此致残、促使你考虑自杀的状况，怎么能被理解为一种有益的适应呢？嗯，我认为抑郁症在我们的当代生活中有很多方面并不能很好地服务于我们。我的观点只是最初的适应是有用的。并不是说抑郁情绪的每一个实例都是有用的。事实上，适应产生的环境与我们当前的环境之间可能存在错配。我还想提出一个人类独有的、在人类抑郁症中独一无二的事情，那就是语言的力量及其对抑郁发作的影响。因为我认为从进化的角度来看，重要的是要记住这种适应在各个物种中都能看到。所以我们可以谈论老鼠抑郁或狗抑郁。但是我的狗，我曾有一只狗，赛勒斯。并且我认为，你知道，在他的生活中可能有时他的环境是不利的。也许他抑郁了。但赛勒斯没有贬低自己。他没有说他作为一只狗失败了。他没有说他本不该出生。对。我的意思是。这很搞笑，但我这是完全认真的。正是因为我们拥有使用语言以及拥有自我观点和自我故事的独特能力，人类的抑郁才会变得更加深沉和可怕。
those feelings so strong. So I agree that our feelings are there to help us do what we need to do in the moment, and that's a future-oriented system. To bear down on this, just a moment longer, you told me how debilitating your depression was, how you felt like there was no end in sight. you even had thoughts of ending your own life. How could a condition that is so disabling, a condition that prompted you to consider suicide, how can this be understood as a beneficial adaptation? Well, I think that there's many things about depression
我们正在使用一些使我们能够将自己与其他物种区分开来的工具，并在某种程度上掌握了整个地球，但这些也是用来对付我们自己的工具。所以，再次强调，这是一个完全好的适应。但在一个高度聪明且使用语言的人手中，我们成了自己最糟糕的敌人。所以在某种程度上，我听到你所说的是，约翰，正如你所讨论的，焦虑的能力是一件好事，也就是说，防范捕食者或威胁很重要。在我们的进化史中，这是一个非常有用的适应。但在我们生活的现代世界中，我们充斥着关于可能具有威胁的事物的故事。
in our contemporary life that are not serving us well. My point only is that the original adaptation is useful. Not that every instance of depressed mood is useful. And in fact, there can be mismatches between the environment in which the adaptation emerged in our current environment. Another thing that I really want to bring up that is unique to humans, in human depression, is the power of language and what that does to depressive episodes. Because I think in an evolutionary perspective, it's important to keep in mind that this adaptation is seen across species. And so we can talk about mouse depression or dog depression. But my dog, I had a dog, Cyrus. And I think that, you know, there probably were times in his life when his environment was unpropitious. And maybe he was depressed. But Cyrus did not get down on himself. He did not say that he was failing as a dog. He didn't say that he should never have been born. Right. I mean this. It's funny, but I mean this in all seriousness. that these are some of the things because of our unique ability to use language and to have a self-view and in a self-story, that human depression can be much, much more deep and terrifying.
我们在阅读博客文章。我们在阅读报纸文章。我们在看有线电视。我们在社交媒体上。我们不断被告知环境中的所有威胁。这种体验恐惧、警惕威胁的自然、健康的适应现在进入了超速运转状态，因为我们处于一个不断一遍又一遍按下那个按钮的环境中。这就是你的观点吗？这就是我的观点。
We're using some of the tools that enabled us to differentiate ourselves from other species and have, in a sense, mastery of the entire Earth, but these are some of the tools that are also used against ourselves. So, again, a perfectly good adaptation. But in the hands of a highly intelligent person using language, we become our own worst enemies. So in some ways, what I hear you saying, John, is that, you know, as you discussed, the capacity for anxiety is a good thing, which is that it's important to be on the lookout for predators or threats. And in our evolutionary history, this was a very useful adaptation. but in the modern world in which we live, we are inundated with stories about things that could be threatening.
我对抑郁症的看法略有不同，因为一些环境因素涉及我们的文化。例如，我们不仅仅体验我们的情绪。我们还根据我们认为自己应该体验的或是我们认为其他人正在体验的来体验我们的情绪。所以社交媒体这种现象确实改变了人们体验情绪的方式，因为人们在社交媒体上经常投射的是一种我过着充满一系列惊人经历的狂喜存在的生活。如果你目睹其他人的社交媒体动态，你可能会开始相信其他人正在经历超乎想象的积极情感，这导致你问这样一个问题：为什么我没有经历这个？
We're reading blog posts. We're reading newspaper articles. We are watching cable television. We're on social media. And we're constantly being told about all the threats that are in our environments. And this natural, healthy adaptation to experience fear, to be a wary of threats, now gets put into hyperdrive because we're in an environment that is constantly pressing that button over and over again. Is that the point that you're making? It is the point that I'm
所以你正在经历一个巨大的差异：你认为你应该感受到的与你正在感受的之间，以及你认为其他人正在感受的之间。所以你的情绪在这个环境中变成了一个大问题。然后你开始问这个问题：我有哪里不对劲，以至于我会有这种感觉？我相信现在有更多的人在问这个问题，超过了人类历史上任何时候问这个问题的人。当然，如果我想象19世纪生活在村庄里的俄罗斯和东欧农民祖先，我不认为他们一直在想：我的感觉方式有什么不对劲？我认为人们更广泛地接受负面情绪也许是意料之中的常态。所以在我们的当代环境中正在发生许多事情，它们可能在加剧低落的情绪。
making. And I make it a little bit different for depression because some of the environmental factors involve our culture. So for example, we don't simply experience our mood. We also experience our mood relative to what we believe we should be experiencing or what we believe other people are experiencing. So this phenomenon of social media has really changed how people experience their mood because what people often project on social media are lives where I am leading an ecstatic existence of a series of amazing experiences. And if you witness other people's social media feeds, you may come to believe that other people are experiencing off the charts positive affect, which leads you to ask the question, why am I not experiencing this?
所以在这里，问题本身可能不是社交比较，因为正如你所指出的，在我们的祖先环境中，也许一些社交比较是有用的。如果有人想出了如何建造比你的小屋更好的小屋，那么你就会学会自己建造一个更好的小屋。但现在我们面临着与数百万其他人的社交比较，那些更好的运动员，吃着更好晚餐的人，处于更幸福关系中的人。我们不断地问自己一个问题：为什么我有所欠缺？完全是这样。而且，你知道，与小屋的例子相反，你可以看到小屋长什么样。但事实是，我们不知道任何人在经历什么。所以在进行这种比较时，我们实际上完全在黑暗中。
So you're experiencing a big discrepancy between what you believe you ought to be feeling and what you are feeling and what you believe other people are feeling. So your mood becomes a big problem in this environment. And then you start to ask the question, what is wrong with me that I feel this way? And I believe that more people are asking that question right now than have ever asked that question in human history. Certainly, if I think about my Russian and Eastern European peasant ancestors in the 19th century who were living in villages, I do not think that they were all the time thinking, what is wrong with the way that I am feeling? I think there was a greater acceptance that negative emotions perhaps were the par for the course to be expected. So there's a number of things that are going on in our contemporary environment that are probably exacerbating low mood.
我们所拥有的只是别人所说的话或别人看起来的样子。不幸的是，在我们的文化中，对于低落情绪并没有太多的透明度。人们不想在他们的Facebook个人资料上发布：我今天情绪低落。当人们发布这样一件事时，往往不知道该如何反应。你也观察到，约翰，我们的现代文化导致人们以可能为自己带来不快乐的方式追求幸福。你这是什么意思？
So here again, you know, the problem might not be social comparison per se, because again, as you point out, in our ancestral environments, perhaps some social comparison was useful. If somebody figured out how to build a better hut than your hut, then you learn to build a better hut yourself. But now we're confronted with social comparison with millions of other people, people who are better athletes, people who are eating nicer dinners, people who are in happier relationships. And we're constantly asking ourselves the question, why is it that I have fallen short? Completely. And, you know, as opposed to the example of the hut, well, you see what the hut looks like. But the truth is, we don't know what anyone is experiencing. So we're really in the dark fundamentally when we make this comparisons.
嗯，我相信在我们的当代环境中，很多人为自己设定了非常不切实际的目标。例如，年轻人说，我要成为亿万富翁，或者我要在社交媒体上积累1000万粉丝，或者我要成为最漂亮的人，这样我就可以成为时装模特，人们会跟随我走遍全世界，不幸的是，极少数人会在这些非常不切实际的目标上取得成功。因此，如果你的幸福取决于达成这些目标，你往往会感到沮丧。约翰，你能谈谈在美国，我们实际上如何将对幸福的追求写入了我们的基本文献之一吗？
All we have are what other people say or what other people look like. And unfortunately, in our culture, there isn't a lot of transparency about low mood. People don't want to post on their Facebook profile. I'm having a low mood day. And people often don't know how to react when they do post such a thing. You also observe, John, that our modern culture leads people to prehistoric. pursue happiness in ways that may set themselves up for unhappiness. What do you mean by this?
你认为这对我们的精神状态有什么影响？嗯，追求幸福的想法显然非常古老，你说得对，托马斯·杰斐逊将其作为人类的基本抱负写入了《独立宣言》。我认为问题在于如何追求幸福，对吧？所以，幸福是你在追求生活中其他有意义的事情的过程中沿途体验到的东西吗？例如，组建家庭、有意义的工作或帮助他人，还是幸福本身就是目的？这意味着，我现在就要幸福，我需要弄清楚我今天要怎么做才能现在就感到快乐。这些是截然不同的。我认为很多人
Well, I believe in our contemporary environment, a lot of people have developed very unrealistic goals for themselves. For example, in young people saying, I'm going to be a billionaire, or I'm going to amass 10 million followers on social media, or I'm going to be the most beautiful so that I be a fashion model and people will follow me all around the world, that unfortunately, very few people will succeed at these very unrealistic goals. And consequently, if your happiness is contingent on reaching these goals, you will tend to feel depressed. Can you talk a moment, John, about how in the United States we've actually written the pursuit of happiness into one of our foundational documents.
已经开始训练自己将幸福视为一种短期现象。我不确定托马斯·杰斐逊是否认为追求幸福意味着18世纪的农民需要找到一种在今天体验欣快感的方法。我们的文化已经接受了这样一种观念：抑郁是我们内部破碎的迹象。但约翰在情感科学方面的研究表明，抑郁可能源于帮助我们适应和生存的同一种情绪系统。我们回来后，将讲述一个关于抑郁症的新故事，一个提供更多理解和希望的故事。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。
what do you think that does to our mental states? Well, the idea of pursuing happiness obviously is very old, and you're right, Thomas Jefferson, included that in the Declaration of Independence as a fundamental human aspiration. I think the question is how to pursue happiness, right? So is it that happiness is something that you experience along the way as you pursue other things that are meaningful in your life. So, for example, starting a family or meaningful work or helping others, or is happiness an end in itself? Meaning, I want happiness now and I need to figure out what I will do today to feel happy right now. Those are very different. And I think many people
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。心理学家约翰·罗滕伯格研究抑郁症及其来源。如果你有关于自己与情绪战斗的个人故事，或者愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的后续问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制语音备忘录。将其发送电子邮件至Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行：抑郁症。该电子邮件地址再次是Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。约翰，你说你反击抑郁症缺陷模式的努力的一部分，
have started to train themselves on thinking about happiness as a short-term phenomenon. And I'm not sure that Thomas Jefferson was thinking that the pursuit of happiness meant that the 18th century farmers needed to find a way to experience euphoria today. Our culture has embraced the idea that depression is a sign of something broken within us. But John's research in affective signs suggests that depression might emerge from the same mood system that helps us to adapt and survive. When we come back, writing a new story about depression, one that offers greater understanding and hope. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
是调查你所谓的抑郁症和其他心理障碍中的一线生机。你所说的一线生机是什么意思？历史上，人们的观点一直是，当人们经历抑郁时，他们会经历进一步的损害。每一次抑郁发作都会损害你的人际关系、损害你的身体、损害你的大脑。而这忽略了人们如何从抑郁发作中积极适应和学习。以及这些发作如何真正成为意义的引擎、变革的引擎、迈向更好未来的引擎。而这个人实际上——我讨厌这么说，因为我认为很多人觉得这很难接受——因祸得福。在你自己的抑郁过程中，你自己也学到了一些重要的东西。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist John Rottenberg studies depression and where it comes from. If you have a personal story about your own battles with your moods, or follow-up questions or comments that you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, depression. That email address again is Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. John, you say that part of your effort to push back against the defect model of depression
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家约翰·罗滕贝格研究抑郁症及其成因。如果您有关于自己与情绪抗争的个人经历，或者希望与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的后续问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录一段语音备忘录。将其发送至我们的邮箱 Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请写：抑郁症。该邮箱地址再次重复是 Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。约翰，你说你努力反击抑郁症缺陷模型的一部分，
is to investigate what you call silver linings in depression and other psychological disorders. What do you mean by silver linings? Well, historically, the idea has been that as people experience depression, they experience further damage. Each episode of depression damages your relationships, damages your body, damages your mind. And that leaves out the active ways that people adapt and learn from their depressive episodes. And the ways that these episodes can actually be engines of meaning, engines of change, engines for a better future. And the person is actually, I hate to say it, because I think many people find this difficult to accept the better for it. In the course of your own depression, you learn some important things yourself.
是去调查你所谓的抑郁症及其他心理障碍中的积极一面。你所说的积极一面是什么意思？嗯，从历史上看，人们的看法一直是，当人们经历抑郁症时，他们会遭受进一步的损害。每一次抑郁发作都会损害你的人际关系、损害你的身体、损害你的心灵。这忽略了人们适应抑郁发作并从中吸取教训的积极方式，以及这些发作实际上如何成为意义的引擎、改变的引擎、走向更好未来的引擎。而且这个人实际上，我很不想这么说，因为我认为许多人很难接受这一点，结果反而变得更好了。在你自己的抑郁经历中，你自己也学到了一些重要的东西。
One of them is that people were really there for you. That's deeply true. I started out, I think, as a 24-year-old, lotably as an independent person, but I learned through my depression how much it's okay to lean on other people and that everyone gets a turn. I'm wondering whether you felt greater empathy for others who've been through the same thing as a result of going through so much suffering yourself. I did, and I don't think it's only me. I think another, you could say, silver lining of depression is that you do develop compassion for other people's suffering. And because you have, it could be that other people are suffering for a different reason, or it may be a different variety of suffering. But you are a little bit more attuned to that pain. And that is in some ways, in some ways, it's a good thing because it's a way that you're in touch with a part of your fundamental humanity in the deeper way. But that's not the only kind of irony of suffering. I think that also from suffering deeply, you can come to appreciate not suffering in a more profound way,
其中之一是人们真的会在你身边支持你。这绝对是真的。我开始时，我想，作为一个24岁的人，很明显是一个独立的人，但我在抑郁中学会了依赖他人是多么正常，每个人都有轮流得到帮助的时候。我想知道，经历过如此多的痛苦之后，你是否对有同样经历的人产生了更多的同理心。我是这样的，而且我觉得不仅我一个人。我想，可以说，抑郁症的另一个积极意义在于，你确实对别人的痛苦产生了同情心。而且因为你经历过，可能是因为别人在为了不同的原因痛苦，或者可能是不同种类的痛苦。但你会对那种痛苦更加敏感。从某种程度上说，这在某些方面是一件好事，因为这是一种与你内心深处更深层次的人性保持联系的方式。但这并不是痛苦唯一的讽刺之处。我认为，同样由于深深地痛苦过，你也能以更深刻的方式学会欣赏没有痛苦的状态，
meaning that I wake up today and I'm not in pain. And that is beautiful. In a way that I don't think I could appreciate before I struggled with depression. And not to say that everyone who's going through life who hasn't experienced depression or some other mental health crisis is sleepwalking through life, I wouldn't say that. But I do think that the experience of being depressed, of being suicidal is something that can make you appreciate normality, if that's a phrase. in a more robust way than if you hadn't had this experience in the first place. You told me when you were describing your depression that at times it felt like it was bigger than you, that it was stronger than you, that you were dealing with the force that in some ways was much more powerful than you were. But at the same time, John, you are here today. Your depression isn't.
这意味着我今天醒来时并没有感到痛苦。这太美妙了。这种感觉是我在与抑郁症抗争之前无法体会到的。这并不是说每个经历人生、没有经历过抑郁或其他心理健康危机的人都在梦游般地生活，我不会这么说。但我确实认为，经历过抑郁、经历过有自杀倾向的过程，确实能让你以一种比从未有过这种经历更深刻的方式去欣赏“正常”——如果可以这样称呼的话。你在描述你的抑郁时曾告诉我，有时它感觉比你更大，比你更强大，你正在应对一种在某些方面比你强大得多的力量。但与此同时，约翰，你今天还在这里。你的抑郁症已经不在了。
I know. This is one thing that keeps me going. The analysis, that I was able to persevere and none of us, I hate to say, is immune from depression or even suffering. Suffering is inevitable. It's really how we are able to tolerate it and work with it and hopefully integrated into our lives that really enables us to move forward. There have been a number of studies that I've also found that people who are experiencing depression in some ways can have a more accurate view of reality than people who are not depressed, that when we are in a low mood, in a bad mood, sometimes we might actually be able to see ourselves to see the situation more clearly. And in some ways, this aligns with your thesis that if a low mood is designed to make us
我知道。这是支撑我继续前行的动力之一。这种分析表明，我能够坚持下来，而且坦率地说，我们当中没有人能对抑郁甚至痛苦免疫。痛苦是不可避免的。关键在于我们如何去承受它、如何与它相处，并希望将其融入我们的生活，这才是真正能让我们继续前进的关键。也有不少研究发现，在某种程度上，经历抑郁的人可能比没有抑郁的人对现实有更准确的看法，当我们在情绪低落、心情不好时，有时我们实际上可能能够更清晰地看清自己和形势。在某种程度上，这与你的观点不谋而合，即如果低落的情绪旨在让我们
stop and think and ponder, perhaps we're able to stop and think and ponder better than when we are in euphoric mood. It's probably true. I'm not arguing that we should all encourage ourselves to be depressed, so we'll process the world in a more accurate way. But I think we should also be attuned to the ways that being in a good mood is consistent with having some, you could say, positive illusions. So we temporarily suspend or put to the side big things like that we are mortal, that we are all going to die and that all the people that we care about are going to die, too, that we temporarily don't focus on the suffering and the bad news that's happening on every continent. And that's totally understandable in that when you're depressed, you become much more attuned to these hard truths is very much a mixed blessing.
停下来思考和沉思，也许我们比处于狂喜状态时更能停下来思考和沉思。这可能是真的。我并不是在争辩说我们都应该鼓励自己去抑郁，这样我们就能以更准确的方式处理世界。但我认为我们也应该意识到，好心情往往与持有某种所谓的“积极错觉”相一致。因此，我们暂时搁置或抛开了那些重大事实，比如终有一死、我们终将死去、我们在乎的人也终将死去，我们暂时不去关注那些在各个大陆发生的痛苦和坏消息。完全可以理解的是，当你抑郁时，你会对这些残酷的真相变得更加敏感，这绝对是一把双刃剑。
But it is something that is a part of this low mood syndrome that we think about things. We think about things deeply and that we don't look away from the pain or the painful things. In fact, we immerse ourselves in the pain and the difficult things. You've also indicated that in some ways your own depression was the origin story of your research career as a psychologist. In some ways, it seems odd to say this, but depression helped. you find your purpose in life? Oh, it definitely helped me find my purpose in life. There's no question about that. It's strange thing to say, but I think truthful thing to say is that I feel grateful that I was able to make this big change in my life, even though it was extraordinarily
但这确实是这种低情绪综合征的一部分，我们会思考事情。我们会深入思考，并且我们不会回避痛苦或痛苦的事情。事实上，我们让自己沉浸在痛苦和困难的事情中。你也曾指出，在某种程度上，你自己的抑郁症是你作为心理学家的研究生涯的起源故事。从某种程度上说，这样说似乎很奇怪，但抑郁症帮助你找到了人生的目标？哦，它绝对帮助我找到了人生的目标。这是毫无疑问的。说这话很奇怪，但我觉得说实话是，我感到很感激自己能够做出生活中的这个重大转变，尽管它是极其
painful, and it put me at risk. I think I was at grave risk for not making it to the other side, but I have now been on the other side for some decades, and I don't think any of this would have happened if I had continued in history. I want to take a moment and underline something really important. You've studied some of the silver linings that come with depression. You've challenged the idea that depression is a brain disorder or merely about errors in cognition. Some people might listen to this and say, okay, John Rottenberg thinks that the, the enterprise of treating depression with psychotherapy or medications is flawed. They should be discarded. That is not what you are saying, right, John? Absolutely. I would love for there to be less
痛苦的，并且让我处于危险之中。我想我当时有无法挺过这一关的巨大风险，但我现在已经走出来几十年了，如果我继续沿着历史的轨迹走下去，这一切都不会发生。我想花一点时间强调一件非常重要的事情。你研究过随抑郁症而来的一些积极意义。你挑战了那种认为抑郁症是一种大脑疾病或仅仅是认知错误的观点。有些人听到这里可能会说，好吧，约翰·罗滕贝格认为用心理治疗或药物治疗抑郁症的事业是有缺陷的，应该被抛弃。约翰，这不是你的意思吧？当然不是。我很希望这个世界上能少一些
depression in the world, and I am very interested in trying to understand how people can experience well-being despite a history of depression, how people can avoid having future episodes of depression. depression is demoralizing and it often leads people to be profoundly hopeless. So I am delighted to be able to say that there are treatments and people should absolutely try psychotherapy. They should absolutely try medications if they've found that they're not able to resolve the episode on their own. And they should also rely, they should also try to get help from the people around them because it often is all of the above, approach that really enables people to make the kinds of changes that are needed in order to
抑郁症，我非常热衷于试图了解人们如何在经历过抑郁症的情况下依然能够体验到幸福感，人们如何才能避免未来再次发作抑郁症。抑郁症会让人士气低落，而且常常让人感到彻底绝望。所以我很高兴能说，现在有治疗方法，人们绝对应该尝试心理治疗。如果他们发现自己无法独自解决这一阶段的问题，他们绝对应该尝试药物治疗。他们还应该依靠、尝试从周围的人那里获得帮助，因为这通常是一个全方位的综合方法，真正能够让人做出必要的改变，以便能够
fully recover from depression. So I believe that treatment is often a critical first step towards recovering and ultimately thriving after depression. I understand, John, that a few years ago you reached out to one of the psychiatrists who treated you when you were depressed. Why did you reach out and how did the conversation unfold? I did. It was something that I thought about a lot. This was actually the psychiatrist who admitted me to the hospital at Johns Hopkins for a month. And he had been working with me for over a year. We had tried, I wouldn't say everything, but we had tried many medications together and in combination. And I felt that he had done his absolute best, but also that he hadn't been able to make me better. And I felt a certain amount of guilt that I wasn't a good patient at the time. And I also felt like he didn't know me, despite the fact that we had the most intimate conversations for like 18 months. And so when I finally did recover, I thought about Dr. McGuinness. And he had become a pretty eminent research psychologist at the University of Michigan. And I just wondered, what would it, what would it be like if I reached out to him? Like, would he remember me? would he be surprised that I had not only gotten out of the depression, but that I was now in the field. And not only I was in the field, I was studying depression, and I was a faculty member like he was.
完全从抑郁症中恢复。因此，我相信治疗通常是恢复以及最终在抑郁症后蓬勃发展的关键第一步。约翰，我听说几年前你联系了当年你抑郁时为你治疗的一位精神科医生？你为什么联系他，你们当时的谈话是如何进行的？我联系了。这是我经常思考的一件事。这实际上是那个在约翰·霍普金斯医院让我住院一个月的精神科医生。他和我合作了一年多。我们尝试了——我不能说尝试了一切，但我们一起尝试了许多药物以及药物组合。我觉得他已经尽力了，但他也确实没能让我好起来。我内心感到有些内疚，觉得自己当时并不是一个好病人。我也觉得他并不真正了解我，尽管我们曾进行过长达18个月的最亲密的对话。所以当我最终康复后，我想到了麦吉尼斯医生。他已经成为密歇根大学一位相当杰出的研究型心理学家。我只是在想，如果我联系他会怎么样？他会记得我吗？他会惊讶于我不仅走出了抑郁，而且现在也进入了这个领域吗？不仅进入了这个领域，我还在研究抑郁症，而且像他一样是一名教职员工。
And so I wrote him with really very little expectation. Just, I really wanted to say that I knew that he had done his best. He was a very kind, is a very kind man. in that it was just a really difficult depression that really I don't know if anyone could have done better than he did and just see, just see what he said. And not only did he write me back, he wanted to talk with me. And we continue to be in contact and I've seen him in person. And to me, this was very gratifying because he is someone who,
所以我写信给他时，真的没有什么期望。只是，我真的很想告诉他，我知道他当时已经尽力了。他是一个非常善良的人，现在也是一个非常善良的人。那只是一场非常艰难的抑郁症，说实话，我不知道是否有人能比他做得更好，我只是想看看，看看他说什么。他不仅给我回信了，他还想和我交谈。我们至今仍在保持联系，而且我已经亲自见过他了。对我来说，这非常令人欣慰，因为他是一个
knew me as the depressed John, but also as the person who's on the other side of depression. And he's one of the few people who really knows all of those parts intimately. And he also is someone who really understands depression. So I think in addition to it being very gratifying for me, I think it was also gratifying for him to see that his patient finally was able to get out of it and turn his life into something that is an asset to the world. In our companion story to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we explore John's ideas about how it's possible to live a good life, even to flourish, if you or someone you know has depression.
既了解我作为抑郁时的约翰，也了解走出抑郁后的我的人。他是为数不多真正深入了解所有这些部分的人。他也确实是一个真正理解抑郁症的人。所以除了对我来说非常欣慰之外，我认为看到自己的病人最终能够摆脱困境，并把自己的生活变成对世界有价值的资产，对他来说也同样令人欣慰。在本期节目的配套故事中，该故事仅供“隐藏大脑Plus”（Hidden Brain Plus）订阅者专享，我们探讨了约翰关于如何过上好生活、甚至如何蓬勃发展的观点，无论你还是你认识的人是否患有抑郁症。
If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled, Flourishing After Depression. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hiddenbrain. You can get a free seven-day trial in both places. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content, including past episodes. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.com slash hidden brain. John Rottenberg is a psychologist at Cornell University.
如果你是订阅者，该节目现在即可收听。它的标题是《抑郁之后的蓬勃发展》。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。在这两个地方你都可以获得为期七天的免费试用。你将立即获得我们所有订阅者专享内容的访问权限，包括往期节目。再次说明，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.com/hiddenbrain。约翰·罗滕贝格是康奈尔大学的心理学家。
He's the author of The Depths, the Evolutionary Origins of the Depression Epidemic. John, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. It was such a pleasure. If you have a personal story about your own battles with your moods, or follow-up questions or comments that you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org.
他是《深渊：抑郁症流行的进化起源》一书的作者。约翰，非常感谢你今天做客“隐藏大脑”。谢谢你邀请我。这真是太高兴了。如果你有关于自己与情绪抗争的个人故事，或者愿意与“隐藏大脑”听众分享的后续问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两到三分钟就足够了。将文件发送至我们的邮箱：feedback@hiddenbrain.org。
Use the subject line, depression. That email address again is feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Also, if you are someone you love is struggling with suicidal thoughts, there are people who can help. If you're in the U.S., you can call or text the suicide and crisis lifeline at 988. That number again is 988. If you're outside the U.S., check the episode notes for today's conversation to find information about support in your location.
邮件主题请写：抑郁症。再重复一遍邮箱地址是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。此外，如果你或你爱的人正在与自杀念头作斗争，有人可以提供帮助。如果你在美国，可以拨打或发短信至自杀与危机生命线，号码是 988。再重复一遍这个号码是 988。如果你在美国境外，请查看今天对话的节目备注，寻找你所在地区的支援信息。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Thank you to Loom by Atlassian for sponsoring the Hidden Brain Perceptions tour. With Loom, teams move work forward faster, replacing endless meetings and slow approvals with quick, clear
“隐藏大脑”由“隐藏大脑传媒”制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐藏大脑”的执行主编。感谢 Atlassian 旗下的 Loom 赞助“隐藏大脑感知之旅”。通过 Loom，团队可以更快地推进工作，用快速、清晰的
video messages. Today we'll hear from Dr. Molly Sands, head of the teamwork lab at Atlassian, about how Lume is transforming the way teams work. I'm Dr. Molly Sands, and I lead the teamwork lab at Atlassian, which is our future of work research and innovation group. If I could wave the magic wand and change something about teamwork, I would stop teams from using meetings for every single thing. I wish teams would embrace asynchronous communication, so sharing updates or feedback in ways that don't require everyone to drop what they're doing at the same time. Loom is a video messaging platform that lets you quickly record and share updates, walkthroughs,
视频消息取代无休止的会议和缓慢的审批。今天我们将听到 Atlassian 团队协作实验室负责人莫莉·桑兹博士关于 Loom 如何改变团队工作方式的分享。我是莫莉·桑兹博士，我领导 Atlassian 的团队协作实验室，这是我们的未来工作研究与创新小组。如果我能挥动魔杖改变团队协作的一点，我会阻止团队把所有事情都开会解决。我希望团队能够拥抱异步沟通，即以不需要每个人同时放下手头工作的方式分享更新或反馈。Loom 是一个视频消息平台，可让你快速录制和分享更新、演练、
or feedback without scheduling another meeting. The magic of Loom is that it feels really personal, like someone tapping you on the shoulder, but it's actually asynchronous. Lou makes it very easy for teams to share and get the information they need in last time. And the more that teams use Loom to communicate and to capture conversations, the smarter their AI-enabled knowledge bases get.
或反馈，而无需安排另一次会议。Loom 的神奇之处在于它感觉非常个人化，就像有人在拍你的肩膀，但实际上它是异步的。Loom 让团队可以非常轻松地在更短时间内共享并获取所需的信息。而且团队越是使用 Loom 进行沟通和记录对话，他们由人工智能驱动的知识库就会变得越聪明。
It lets people design their day around their energy and around their priorities instead of being trapped by their meeting schedule. Thanks again to Lume for sponsoring the Perceptions Tour. Loom is AI-first-powered video communication that moves teams forward, whether you're sharing feedback, obtaining approvals, or setting context. Reduce unnecessary meetings and make the ones that matter more effective. So unstuck your teams today at loom.com.
它让人们能够根据自己的精力和优先级来安排一天的时间，而不是被会议日程所束缚。再次感谢 Loom 赞助感知之旅。Loom 是由人工智能优先驱动的视频沟通工具，无论你是分享反馈、获取审批还是设定背景，都能推动团队前进。减少不必要的会议，让重要的会议更高效。今天就让你的团队在 loom.com 解脱出来。
That's L-O-O-O-M dot com. It's a team changer. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 L-O-O-O-M 点 com。这是一个改变团队的工具。我是尚卡尔·韦达姆。回头见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。